qui adorent mais on se retrousse les
manches pour tout nettoyer je me trouve
ici là où la rivière a tellement été
gonflée par les pluies diluviennes
qu'elle est fournie
elle a envahi la ville et elle s'est
engouffrée comme un torrent dans la rue
jusqu'à un mètre 82 auteur forçant les
habitants à se réfugier au premier étage
de leur maison parfois jusqu'à trente
six heures d'affilée sans nourriture
sans eau potable sans électricité dans
le centre historique de la ville aussi
qui est beaucoup plus touristiques on
s'active avec énergie on nettoie on
déblaie ou vides parce que l'enjeu c'est
de rouvrir au plus vite au plus fort de
la saison touristique
les restaurateurs les commerçants les
hôteliers travaillent d'arrache-pied
comme j'adore ce jeune hôtelier que nous
avons rencontrée un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui écouter le moment la
priorité de déblayer tous afin de devoir
tout au clair et nettoyer un maximum
pour pour essayer de réouvrir au lundi
parce que c'est les quinze jours qui
sont ici pour le moment c'est les 15
plus gros jour de l'année donc et on
attend les assurances pour prendre des
photos savoir ce qu'on peut jeter pas
acheter guerre d essai de ranger au
maximum puis on essaye de faire un état
des lieux aussi savoir ce qu'il
fonctionne ce qu'on doit racheter les
frigos les un peu tout savoir ce que le
sinistre a cassé voilà l'allemagne et
bien sûr le pays le plus touché on
redoute que le bilan humain ne
s'alourdisse encore puisque des dizaines
de personnes sont toujours portées
disparues on craint aussi les
glissements terrain comme celui qui
s'est produit dans la commune d'arsac où
toute une partie de
de la commune a tout simplement disparu
a été englouti les régions les plus
touchées sont la rhénanie palatinat et
la rhénanie du nord westphalie où dix
neuf mille secouristes ont été déployés
le quotidien allemand le plus lu le
quotidien binta titré sur les
inondations de la mort et c'est sans
contexte la catastrophe naturelle la
plus grave qu'ait connue l'allemagne
depuis au moins une cinquantaine
d'années ici gabriel jazzer radio canada
aujourd'hui en belgique